okay so stranger things season 4 ends
with the biggest cliffhanger in the
show's history there's a storm coming
and season 5 is set to be the final
entry of the netflix phenomenon all the
pieces of the game are now on the board
and we not only know who the villain is
but also what they're after it also
seems like they've won as well due to
the doorway to hell being unleashed on
hawkins we are told throughout season 4
that if wekner kills max then the final
sacrifice will be complete and he'll be
able to unleash the dark dimension on
the unsuspecting city this is why the
gateway opens as technically he does
kill her even though she's brought back
and that kind of takes me into my first
theory which is that wekner likely has
max's soul and getting it back will be
the way to close the doorway theory time
is getting a little bit played out now
so we're completely scrapping that for
this video and coming up with a totally
new unseen idea it's incredible how
creative we are at the channel and it's
now hypothesis time hypothesis time
hypothesis time shout out to raj here
for that one and i think that all those
that have died in the upside down might
exist within wekner in some way huge
thank you to reddit user ezra88 who
pointed out that after henry killed all
the kids in the lab that he said they
weren't gone they were there with him in
his mind very important line and this
could hint at those he kills being able
to come back in some form or another now
the most obvious person i think this
would apply to is of course max when we
last left her she was in an unresponsive
coma stuck in a hospital bed the doctors
couldn't explain how she'd managed to
come back to life and upon entering her
mind else saw that it was about as empty
as the pope's tinder account
she's just not there but the fact that
she's still ticking could mean that
wekner has taken his soul i've already
done a full video breaking down how vac
now might be inside her using her body
as a vessel to sustain his life after
his last one's destruction i don't want
to just go over that again but it will
be linked on screen right now if you
want to see us break it all down anyway
moving on in the complete opposite
direction to that if max is inside
beckner's mind she could end up coming
back to her body after his defeat
however she could also potentially roam
around in there too and she may even
come across the other kids from the lab
that are trapped there as well all these
psychic beings could end up teaming up
with 11 and it might actually lead to
wekner's downfall if they all work
together there was this big section in
the season where they talked about how
max actually managed to enter vector's
mind at the creel house and this is how
she escaped hitting at this potentially
coming back around huge shout outs to
think story for also theorizing that if
bad memories killed someone that happy
memories could be used to also bring
them back in his ending explained video
he went over how we got a lot of focus
on max's memories and how they may be
weaponized to resurrect her down the
line now if max counts as the final
sacrifice that opened the doorway then
bringing her fully back to life may also
mean that the ritual gets reversed that
seems to be the main reason why the
dimensions start to tear across the town
and therefore if she's fully resurrected
it should start to close it off the
portals in the area appear at the spot
that his victims were killed and this
includes things like eddie's trailer the
road the lake and the attic in the creel
house their bodies are also strung up in
wekner's home so potentially saving
characters like this could bring them
back and close the portals this idea of
characters coming back is also being
heavily discussed in the case of eddie
guy played his final concert in the
series and he was killed by the demo
bats in the last episode i've seen tons
of fan theories for how he's alive on my
videos including that their poison only
paralyzes people how he could have ended
up being trapped in wekner and a lot
more i do think he's dead but joseph
quinn who plays eddie also had some
ideas for how he could come back when
talking to the radio times he said that
both he and joe kiri had been firing
ideas backwards and forwards and he said
that they'd come up with a few this
included a supernatural element like him
being resurrected in the upside down or
even something as simple as him just
appearing as a vision in dustin's mind
because of this i think he could be
brought back in the same way that billy
returned if we look at dustin he fits
the mold of being one of beckner's
victims like max he likely harbors a lot
of guilt over eddie's passing just like
how billy ended up being the reason that
wekner was able to strike this could end
up being the case in dustin if this ends
up being true then eddie could end up
being used as a way to taunt him let me
know below if you agree or not and if
you're enjoying the video so far then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this almost every day if this is
your first time here then welcome to the
heavy spoiler show i'm your host paul
now let's get into the rest of the
stranger things theories now i also
think that we might have got a hint
towards one of the upcoming monsters for
the fifth season stranger things has
kept up the idea that they're all
somewhat tighter dungeons and dragons
and this is something that's happened
throughout each entry in the eighth
episode will ends up showing like a
painting and this has a three-headed
dragon on it i actually think this might
be teasing what's coming down the line
and the battle that we see playing out
here could end up being brought into
live action for the show according to
dungeons and dragons law this could be
the creature tiermet a multi-header
dragon based on the god of the same name
who appeared in eternals although wagner
is the big bad now that the mind player
has been downgraded a bit i think they
need to bring in something new to work
as one of his ways to attack hawkins
there was also the stranger things that
steve and co kept hearing in the upside
down at multiple points they heard weird
noises that could be foreshadowing this
beast's arrival this would be a great
way to set that up and hopefully we get
something along those lines come the
next season
also will just tell a mate yeah just
tell them we all know everyone knows now
will could also be instrumental in
defeating wekner as he clearly still has
a connection to him whilst everyone was
celebrating his downfall will is the
only one who says he's still alive and
he gets the chill on the back of his
neck before the dark clouds roll in now
there's one of two possibilities either
he will be used his way to track and
weaken vechna or he might end up
becoming a vessel for him it's often
been brought up how the mind player
didn't want to kill will he wanted to
kill everyone around him gemstone20 on
youtube touched upon how wekner could
end up wanting to use will as his next
body because he's desperate to return to
the right side up after his last body
was destroyed he could end up attempting
to possess will and wagner and dungeons
and dragons was actually a wizard that
was capable of doing this bekna could
possibly be existing in the shadow
particles right now and he might have
taken on the mind player form now that
he's free from a physical body he of
course spent hours dueling him and he
was fascinated with spiders makes sense
that he try to take this on in the end
because the kid he just bloody loves
them now there's also a lot of theories
at the moment floating around that henry
is 11's biological father which explains
how she has her abilities i think the
whole real dad twist is kind of getting
overdone a bit recently and though i
like it in the boys star wars and so on
i hope they avoid it with this it is
important to bear in mind as well that
11's dad already has the in canon name
of andrew rich plus i'm sure henry was
taken to brenner's lab as a kid and
that's where he stayed until we meet him
later on in the series i doubt he was
hitting up the town and getting women
pregnant so you kids yeah you take your
bloody fan theories and you shove them
up yet
now lastly is the idea that the group
might have to use time travel to defeat
wagner in many ways we've had nodes to
this throughout the season as the clock
has appeared at numerous points and has
been a big focus on the past and present
hell even the upside down is stuck in
1983
aka the day that will enter the upside
down so technically going back there is
like stepping back into the past and
there may be ways inside of it to
reverse time further back than that very
little is known about the dimension and
when we see wekner first exploring it it
looks completely different to how we
typically know it time is a weird thing
in the upside down that definitely
doesn't work the same way as it does for
us so i do kind of hope that they start
exploring that there might even be a
case of reversing time in some way to
stop beckner when he's younger and they
might even travel back to the day that
he was sent to the upside down and stop
him from going to it this would reverse
all the events kind of the show but that
might be a way to stop him and bring
everyone back because that's what i
really care about now we also think that
11 will fly next time as there's been a
lot of talk about this mike said it
brennan said it and there's also the
supergirl reference that pops up in the
finale clearly hints towards this and
this might be how she travels to the
upside down at great speeds anyway
that's the end of hypothesis time and
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
below also steve he's gonna nancy now
the series is rumored to be returning in
2024 so there's plenty of time to talk
about what we think may happen we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts and theories we picked the
comments at random on the 15th and the
witness of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want to watch that max wekina video then
that will be linked on screen right now
so go head over there right after this
by the way thanks for sitting through
this i've been poor i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you